well this works out really well it's on
my way home from blue planet stopping by
camp this year I found it in 2012 it's
I'll tell you more about the company but
part of the impetus to found blue planet
was I was at a Gordon conference on
biomineralization which is my field and
I've taught it I don't know here on
campus it's about 98 or something like
that and one of the guys presenting his
PhD work had discovered this liquid
phase of carbon that we hadn't
previously appreciated which over the
last few years we've come to realize
it's really important in
biomineralization how clams grow and
coral skeletons and things it's called a
liquid condensed phase and it's in our
blood plasma it's in sea water it's in
drinking water and it's the way carbon
blue carbon exists in aqueous solutions
and there's a new device called a nano
particle tracking a device which is
different than dynamic light scattering
or anything like that it allows us to
see these things and as soon as I saw
that I realized immediately it was going
to really revolutionize the way we could
capture and handle carbon and he had a
lot of opportunities but he wanted to
come and join Blue Planet and you know
he and a few of the other team of PhDs I
got together are still there the what we
do is we capture carbon dioxide and we
turn it into building materials and
there's a few aspects of this is one is
that we're not trying to purify co2
there's a there's a belief out there
that there's something to do with co2 if
you could capture it and the fact is
there's no use for co2 it's just a you
know it's a great raw material but
purified co2 has almost no value you
know you can use it for coca-cola that
very small amount but over 99% of all
the money that's gone toward addressing
carbon has gone under this belief that
it would be a value to us if we could
capture and purify large amounts of
carbon dioxide and there's no value to
it at all that's why the only thing they
can think to do with it is pumping into
the ground is a waste and which is very
expensive and so you know fundamentally
the whole concept that we need to go out
and purify a bunch of co2 and have pure
co2 is I mean I'm sorry to say it's just
a complete waste of time and energy and
hope and and everything there's nothing
to do with all that co2 we can use a
little bit of it for it enhanced oil
recovery and it's going to come back out
of the ground so a key aspect of what we
do is we don't purify co2 we just
convert it to carbonate we're not trying
to purify anything no the energy
associated with purification we don't do
any of that a big aspect is if you're
going to capture significant amounts of
anthropogenic co2 and by the way I do
have all the questions written down and
I'll address the questions I'll zip
through the slides sort of fast you need
something that's going to take a few
tens of billions of tons a year
those co2 if it's taking tens of
millions of tons or hundreds of millions
of tonnes it's it's not even going to be
a blip on the climate curve right so if
you just put in perspective the largest
carbon sequestration project in the
world today is being developed by the
province of Saskatchewan by SATs power
and their goal over a few billion
dollars of spending over
few years is to sequester 1 million tons
of carbon dioxide so there's you know
it's a thousand millions in a billion
we're talking about 10 to 20 billion
tons right so you need thousands of
these 5 billion dollar plants with
places to inject it in the ground with
the money to pay for its monitoring and
insurance over decades sort of maybe
centuries to even do it so you can
almost ask the question why are they why
are the Canadians spending five billion
dollars and I don't have an answer to
that you know senator Dorgan spent five
billion dollars in illinois on the
future gen project before they gave that
one up and they're all trying to purify
co2 an injection in the ground so the
point is you know however you remove co2
you better have something to do with it
once you got it and other than the
movement of water it turns out the
movement of rock is the largest mass of
material movement on the planet there
are about 50 billion tons of rock mine
and moved every year in poor countries
rich countries tropical countries Nordic
countries the whole economy runs off
concrete in building materials so first
of all you need a place large enough to
put that much co2 that's actually going
to make a blip or actually cover most of
anthropogenic co2 the second thing is
there's tons of great ideas about what
to do with co2 not many at a scale that
could be significant but if if there's
no way to pay for it it doesn't really
matter that much if you have to create
money that doesn't exist to go pay for
it and create a tax and if it were if we
were something like sulfur dioxide which
was handled beautifully by the Clean Air
Act through a cap-and-trade type of
system we handled acid rain in Northeast
in a beautiful
the way but sulfur dioxide exists and
you know hundreds of parts per million
in you know flue gases you know in the
flue gas of a coal-fired power plant its
co2 said one hundred and fifty thousand
parts per million and that there's not
enough money in the world to tax it you
know if in Copenhagen the Chinese told
us that the developing world was going
to have to pay them a hundred dollars a
ton to mitigate their co2 and they need
to mitigate five to ten billion tons of
co2 a year so a hundred dollars times
say ten billion is a pretty big number
there's just not enough money to do it
anyway so that the whole concept that
we're gonna attacks you know we're just
gonna add co2 like another pollutant to
the list that you know NOx Sox co2 will
tax it people stop emitting it's not
realistic it's never gonna happen
it can't be treated just like another
pollutant so if you're gonna actually do
something that's actually going to work
there has to be money to pay for it and
there's every country in the world you
know from the Congo to Australia to
Mongolia to Russia is paying for Rock
today and it's important in the sense
that got the the purchasing power of
government is probably the greatest
lever of governments around the world
have to actually do something about
climate change you know I mean I you
know I was at Copenhagen I helped with
writing this cement section of the
Copenhagen treaty and all that I've seen
how this process works but you know in
Paris there's this wonderful treaty sign
but fact is you know if you looked at
the science issue right after Paris they
pointed out that even if all the
countries fulfilled on their pledges by
2100 were over a hundred billion tons of
co2 going out
compared to today today which is just
under 40
that's if everyone fulfills their
pledges which it looks like there's
almost no way they're gonna fulfill
their pledges so those mechanisms it's
hard to see how they could be effective
at actually having any effect on climate
change what the editors of science did
say was that the use of fossil fuels
would keep increasing through the
century which despite what's happening
in North America and Europe they
absolutely are going to you know when
you talk to we talked to Chinese
partners all the time they have no
concern of co2 largest power companies
in China it's not even on their radar
radar screen they're concerned about
soot because it's a visible pollutant
they're not concerned about co2 there's
no according to them there's no
incentive coming for them to mitigate
their co2 in India and other places so
what the editors are saying is the only
way to really do anything if we look at
primary energy use is to do carbon
capture and sequestration on
biologically derived fuels both fossil
and modern fuels and capture that and by
taking out this wedge we might actually
have a chance and they conclude that
that's probably the single most
important thing that would need to be
done to actually have an effect on
climate change and that assumes that we
go renewables a little more nuclear and
everything so well we're doing a blue
planet is
we've come up with a way to rapidly
deploy units to go out to bioenergy
plants and fossil fuel plants that are
putting off a lot of co2 and convert the
co2 and to carbonate and then make that
into building materials what we're
deploying right now
is a modular unit that's manufactured by
one of the largest manufacturing
companies in the world that has a
presence all over the world but it's
call it a 2 megawatt module and that
means it'll take two megawatts of coal
exhaust and convert it into rock they
can be used in in concrete a key thing
about it is that if someone comes out
and invests in this capital equipment
they'll make a good return on their
investment and that's really where all
the funding needs to come from to
actually address climate change there's
not enough money in government you can't
print enough money to pay for this just
because it's the right thing to do and
there's especially true in Asia and
other places so each module takes about
25 tons of co2 a day at a 50% capture
rate and produces about 40,000 tons of
rockier there's economics associated
with abating the air emissions selling
the product and just to put in
perspective to separate co2 like Kemper
County or FutureGen or in Norway or just
separating co2 from flue gas the capital
cost of the equipment can be four or
five thousand dollars per kilowatt so
for a one gigawatt plant that's like
four to five billion dollars it's never
no one's ever going to pay for that and
it can take 40 to 50 percent of the
power from the power plant just to
separate co2 so being able to do
something it's you know $700 per
kilowatt
is uh is really inexpensive the basic
system takes in raw flue gas captures
co2 from it makes rock which is in red
there sold for aggregate I'll talk about
that it uh uses routine rock materials
to reform a capsular solution and it
regenerates and it's based off a lot of
experience in this area right now if you
go up to the San Francisco Airport
they're building a new terminal and if
you look at the cast-in-place concrete
they're concrete materials consists of
Portland cement fly ash blast furnace
slag normal weight aggregate which is
rock and lightweight aggregate and all
the lightweight aggregate which is on
all the ramps and things in the airport
are they have to be blue planet
aggregate there's no known equal its
they're trying to be the greenest
Airport in the world and a lot of the
other airports are following suit in
that and I'll explain why a carbon
negative material is so attractive but
the whole other side of this is in the
built environment today historically
we've been focused on energy efficiency
like the lights and the heating and all
that in terms of being responsible for
the carbon footprint it's a built
environment and of course lights and
heating are driven by electricity which
creates co2 but there's an architect
named Ed Masseria who spoke to the UN
about this that he has a movement called
architecture 2030 that says by 2030 all
buildings are going to be met carbon
neutral in their operations and normally
when you looked at the carbon footprint
of a building most of the carbon
footprint was due to the operations due
to the heating or the lighting or
something like that about a third was
due to the embodied energy in the
materials and a little bit due to the
construction of the demolition of the
building and that if we if we get that
operational carbon footprint down to
zero like Ed wants to do what's left is
the embodied energy of the building and
in any building you go to almost in the
world the the big part of the carbon
footprint is the concrete secondarily it
might be this steel but it's not the
carpet fibers or the pain or a lot of
the things that get marketed as green
products it's it's the concrete and if
you actually just look at the concrete
alone you can assess the carbon
footprint of a building so if you take
the new Apple campus for example they
had five concrete ready mix plants down
there in a pile of rock aggregate that
was 11 stories high and the the carbon
footprint of the concrete wasn't even
part of the equation right they were
looking at carpet fibers and LED light
bulbs and that kind of thing so there's
no there's a whole new movement in green
building to really understand the carbon
footprint it's not just marketing but in
terms of well you know how BIG's this
market a couple years ago there were 54
billion tons of rock mined by the way
rock mining is all open pit mining it's
not shaft mining yep to put in
perspective coal there's five billion
tons of coal mined every year one-tenth
as much and most of its shaft mining you
know so when you hear about mountaintops
being blown off that's usually not coal
that's rock that's being mined if you
fly into the bay area you'll see quarry
is all around where there's huge scars
on the hills that's rock being mine and
but even at $15 a ton which is a low
price someone somewhere government's
mainly are paying $15 a tonne 454
billion tons of rock so this is the
money that governments can use to
actually seriously address climate
change if they address it properly
that's where their muscle is it's not
signing treaties that there's no money
to pay for
it's to take the money they're already
spending and spend in the right way you
know in a more responsible way and
instead of spending on open pit mining
spin it on rock that's made out of co2
that prevent it from entering the
atmosphere you know and this has been
done before
California has a crumb rubber law so if
you're a pavement contractor and you
want to bid on a Caltrans job you have
to have crumb rubber in your asphalt
that's recycled tires and if you don't
have recycles tired in your asphalt you
can't even bid on the job have you seen
many old tires lying on the road around
here in the last 10 years
like we're importing tires from other
states to put crumb rubber in the
asphalt see that's the muscle of
government it's much stronger than
signing treaties that no one's gonna
follow anyway anyway we we use a process
we call a geometric process sort of like
biomimetic but we we grow our rock very
similar to the sands that occur out on
the great Bahamas bank those white sands
you see that's not Sandra they came from
rivers there's no mountains in the
Bahamas you know forms in place from
seawater in co2 it goes into the sea
water and that's what we do we take
substrates and we grow artificial
limestone right around the substrate and
we make in a way that it's useful in
concrete there's some pictures of some
fine aggregate that's been coated the
one on the right is the actual aggregate
we used at the San Francisco Airport the
coating goes on the outside of the
particles we can take material from just
waste material from a rock quarry and
put it through the process and be left
with a substrate that can be coated and
here's some examples from California and
Florida where we've used different rocks
in the process
and in addition to just regular rocks as
our feedstocks we can process materials
from a variety of industries that are
just waste materials I'll answer a
couple of the questions we're working at
coal plants where we're processing their
ash steel mills we're processing their
slag alumina refineries where we process
the bauxite ore as well as to go into
this Rock product that we're making in
the process right now we're making the
type of concrete we're making is called
lightweight concrete and it can be
pumped up high it's being specified now
you know in a lot of the large buildings
in San Francisco where you have multiple
stories and you're pumping the concrete
at PI and there's structural concerns so
you need a lighter weight concrete this
is it being pumped up on the new
terminal at SFO is it's distributed just
like regular concrete you know concrete
plants they bring in Rock and cement and
admixture in water and put it in cement
trucks there's no new supply chain but
just to kind of give you a feeling of
why this can work is this is you're an
average half a gigawatt 500 megawatt
coal plant and it's in a part of the
world where there's no value to
capturing co2 it's not California or
candidates it's like New Mexico's you
know or Alabama or Michigan or somewhere
where they don't have any carbon laws so
there's no incentive no financial
incentive to get carbon but the the
plant can pay 300 million dollars for
the for a system it'll cost them 120
million to operate it in their revenue
even at $30 a ton which is a low price
is 300 million dollars and they get a 78
percent
turn on their investment blue planet is
just getting a royalty per ton of
aggregate for a year on the system the
system is manufactured by largest
manufacturer of that's this kind of
equipment in the world and I'm going to
run through these kind of fast this is a
coal plant here we are at a cement plant
again no incentive of capturing co2 they
spent 80 million dollars to purchase the
equipment you know almost 40 million to
operate it and they have an annual
revenue of almost 100 million dollars
it's a natural gas plant natural gas is
much more dilute it's three to five
percent co2 so there's a lot less
product produced and again it's a good
investment for them the it is we all
know there are our carbon prices in a
lot of the world and I've retreated to
California and Canada right now until
the rest of the world catches up because
when you talk to anybody in Canada
they're like great let's do this you
know from all levels to some extent in
California once you step over the
California border they haven't even
heard about co2 it's a complete unless
they're shipping power into California
and paying it attacks a surcharge a lot
of people say oh we don't have any coal
in California well look on your PG&E
think it'll list coal renewable all that
and at the bottom it'll say eighteen
percent other you know the you know if
the coal plants I don't why I mean I
said well who's buying your power to say
oh we have contracts with Long Beach
Riverside Modesto you know that's where
all those coal electrons are coming so
but anyway the point is even if you add
on the California carbon tax of $14
it's about the same it doesn't really
affect the overall investment for the
person so I mean it's hard to explain
but you need hundreds of millions of
dollars and billions of dollars to make
this happen and it ain't coming from the
government it's not going to come from
the people purchasing the power or the
cement or the steel it's but it'll come
from from the equity dollars people will
invest in these plants you can't do it
with venture capital I've been there
tried that raised a few hundred million
dollars there's not enough money in
Silicon Valley to even begin even a
little bit to approach this problem you
see that there was a family office
meeting out and Pescadero over the
weekend and all these billionaires are
here and like oh yeah I'm going to fix
the world you know you know you can put
all their checkbooks together and you
couldn't build two or three plants you
know you actually you have to access the
kind of capital it's not in the hundreds
of millions but billions of dollars to
build all these plans to do this anyway
this class is figuring out how to make
profitable companies that that help you
help the world right and you've you've
pivoted from a previous company Calera
which was making I think similar types
of materials but clearly you found
something that's far more profitable so
that's one thing I'm curious about and
then another is you're talking about
really harnessing the power of the
investment government's need to make an
infrastructure anyway and using that
instead of you know a different kind of
policy but it seems to me that you're
able to embed yourself in a policy of
hey airports are required to have
asphalt is required to have rubberized
you know so can you say more about both
of these how this is better than the
cólera a few years ago if if it is I it
seems like it it probably is and how hmm
how how one with a different idea you
know going into a different space would
be able to harness this power of
governmental infrastructure investment
that seems to be driving you these are
both so
so key to what you're doing well color
maids cement we're making rock so
different technology different company
but yeah I mean we in Silicon Valley
where arrogant enough you know with
Google and all that that that's just
another problem and we're smarter than
everybody else and we'll just throw
money at thinks this is way too big for
Silicon Valley there's not you can put
all the money in Silicon Valley together
it wouldn't have any effect on climate
change you know it's it's not a startup
company thing you know and we're talking
changing the fabric of the
infrastructure of society not just North
American and European society but a
society that's being emulated you know
they have eight Lane freeways in China
now you know and that's not going to
happen in so you know with our start-up
thinking you know it's getting into the
basic sort of government you know when
you go to the gas pump and you pump gas
you're paying eight or nine cents I
can't remember in a gasoline tax per
gallon and all that money goes to
Washington DC it's a federal gasoline
tax to the Department of Transportation
and then it's tolled out to the states
so California gets 11 or 12 billion
dollars a year just to buy Rock and
other materials that that's how we're
gonna really do something if governments
around the world wake up and realize
they already have the purchasing muscle
so I'm going to run through these and
we've already kind of addressed you know
if you just wanted to separate co2 and
inject it into the ground which is what
90% of everyone working on this problem
is working on right now because there's
money to do it even though there's no
future in it
you're going to use 40 percent of the
load from a plant so you have a 1
gigawatt plant you use 400 megawatts
just to separate the co2 you're gonna
spend a ridiculous amount on the capital
equipment and then you still need to
transport and monitor and ensure the
carbon and there's no revenue from it
it's just a cost and that's really
different
then spending less money taking less
parasitic load off the plant and making
something that governments are already
buying the first place and I'm gonna
move ahead so we can get to the
questions the this is an example of a
product we're working on if you go over
to Home Depot you see big pallets with
stacks of concrete sacks and most people
say oh well you know that's not a big
deal well actually over half the
concrete poured comes out of sacks if
you go to Mexico 80% the concrete comes
out of sacks you can't get a order a
concrete truck in Mexico City and expect
the country to be delivered because of
the traffic
or India or Indonesia Indonesia to the
fourth largest country in the world they
don't have concrete trucks you know it's
you put you put a Ready Mix point right
on site but there's an interesting
product it's a two-thirds more volume
than a regular socket concrete so it
weighs 80 pounds instead of 60 pounds in
the carbon footprint of that socket
concrete's about 40 pounds per bag if
you brought that up to how much is that
per yard it's about a thousand pounds of
co2 per yard it's about half a ton of
co2 per yard of embodied energy in that
concrete and it's funny one of our
friends and advisors built the Bullitt
Center up in Seattle which is considered
the greenest building in the world and
he he while he was her at Stanford he
invented Earth Day so this guy's you
know environmental God right and someone
said to him well what about the carbon
footprint of the bullet Center
I mean of the concrete well that wasn't
counted you know because we're looking
at the lights and all that so it's it's
just a new nuance to thinking about
green building is the embodied energy so
if we just replace the coarse aggregate
in this concrete with the blue planet
it gets it down to carbon-neutral you
know so a yard of concrete it's now
negative 76 pounds of co2 okay if we if
we replace the fine aggregate meaning
this end we can get it down this
negative several hundred pounds and if
the cement in the concrete came from a
cement plant that has a blue planet
system on it so it's not putting out all
the co2 it goes you know negative half a
ton or so per ton so if I'm placing
10,000 yards of concrete instead of
10,000 yards times half a ton it's ten
thousand yards
Tord times zero times negative half a
ton so the built environment instead of
geologic reservoirs becomes where we're
sequestering the co2 in the built
environment that on day one of a
building has a carbon bank account and
it may never even come up to carbon
neutral in its whole operational
lifetime because it's so
energy-efficient and you know you talk
to carb say well you know you're
developing protocols so shale oil can
inject 18,000 tons of co2 into the
ground in Southern California could you
develop a protocol if we put co2 into
the sidewalk where we get this kind of
credits and hopefully that's where the
where the environments are gonna go is
you know even if if the state of
California you know we import 400
million tons of rockier to this state a
lot of it comes from British Columbia
when we're up doing the San Francisco
Airport tour they have a marine terminal
up there Central concrete does and all
these barges from Orca aggregates and
British Columbia are coming in dumping
limestone that we're exporting at a huge
carbon footprint to build the airport
and you know if you create the rock
locally and use it locally you're not
transporting it and Rock weighs a lot
more than cabbage in terms of you know
locally sourced materials so it makes a
lot of sense to to make the rock
but I do want to mention just for the
students that it the biggest part of any
effort is the team you build and the
people behind it and you know like in
all my companies you know the management
group that I've put together you know
former president of energy companies
people that have built plants with me
before former CEO of one of the largest
construction companies guy that was
director of finance at the Department of
Energy guy built the largest renewable
energy fleet in the world so it's really
helpful to get the brains behind you you
know our scientific advisory board you
know from Don Kennedy - you know Gordon
Brown here at Stanford these are people
that have been working on these problems
for a long time you know in the built
environment you know people like Roger
plot the current president of the US
Green Building Council
David Godfrey who thought up the idea of
lead and the US Green Building Council
when he's here at Stanford in 1968
founder of the US Green Building Council
another former president of the US Green
Building Council you know getting that
kind of advice and also in this on the
government affairs side you know Leo
DiCaprio is a famous actor but he's also
a very influential climate activists and
he can he can he can call up heads of
state and get meetings you know so he's
an investor but he's also active player
and what we're trying to do durwood's
outgrowth the Montreal Protocol I met
him when we were writing the you know
the cop15 30:16 treaty up in Norway and
he's been helping us Dan tag Loreen
around the General Services
Administration which is all the federal
holdings it's the largest real estate
portfolio
lay on the country and he made the whole
thing that's why you have to have LEED
Platinum buildings all federal buildings
because of what Dan was doing so the I
guess they're close I'll just say that
limestone has been around for a while
there's nothing really different about
turning co2 into limestone
that's what most of the carbon on the
planet is in limestone so there's a few
hundred million tons in the in the whole
biosphere I mean I start in the
atmosphere I think about what about four
hundred million billion yeah four
hundred billion tons in the atmosphere
there's a few thousand billion tons in
the UH in the biosphere and I think in
the hydrosphere there's a few tens of
thousands of billions of tons but in
that lithosphere of the earth there's
about 70 million billion tons a carbon
so essentially all the carbon is sitting
in limestone it's not in the atmosphere
or in trees or in the water it's sitting
in limestone so it's it's a pretty
normal thing to do and it's really
interesting you look at the history of
the earth the times when we've formed
the most limestone and limestone is
nearly a hundred percent the fossil
remains of ancient marine organisms all
the times were like the austin chalk the
white close of dover co2 levels when
when this these rocks were formed and
these are just chocolates which are
little plants in the ocean we're about
seven times what they were today so you
know in general the more carbon around
the more carbonate minerals have been
forming so it's a little different than
the way the popular media discusses co2
and
all that I mean I my PhD was on how
corals for him and I'm very familiar
with the physiology of all that but it's
a lot more complicated than you know
making up a shingle like ocean
acidification because that's really not
what's happening at all
but anyway let's hit these questions
some the what are the major challenges
of co2 mineralization technology well
the most important one is scale you know
I don't think doing something it's going
to mineralize a few million tons or a
few hundreds of millions of tons of co2
is really going to make a difference and
so you're working in the billions of
tons and to make mineral you need all
the constituents of the mineral to go
into it so co2 is one of the
constituents but you also need calcium
for example and magnesium and so a major
part of it is sourcing all the raw
materials and you know it's hard to
explain I mean I said a coal plant in
the middle Wyoming a couple of weeks ago
with my caisson we were driving around
and we cross this train track to look at
some stuff on the other side and well
while we cross that this unit train with
a hundred and ten cars of coal in it
came by like three miles an hour well
you know it takes more than a few
minutes for a three mile an hour 100
unit coal 300 and this was it a coal
mine mouth coal plant so this is only
about a third of the coal they were
gonna use that day you know and it's
it's just overwhelming you know you look
off on a horizon and it's just coal cars
and it wasn't even all the coal and you
know next day in southern Wyoming same
thing we're in a cement plant in Alberta
and they bring in 330 train loads of
limestone a week and they grind it all
so you have to think it the same scale
that stuff's happening
in the you know sort of the the
cleantech
module or mode in Silicon Valley it's
okay I'm gonna make a little biofuels
plant and then I'm gonna scale it up and
all that and I think the main thing is
you have to think at scale from the very
beginning and I've told all our people I
don't want to have any equipment that's
not already made by somebody else that's
not an inventory by five different
vendors you know because to scale you
have to get out there and deploy rapidly
part of our modular approach is when you
retrofit into a coal plant or a gas
plant or a bottle fuels plant or
whatever you want to have minimal
disruption minimal permitting time you
want to be able to move things out if
the plant shuts down you know here in
California we're gonna be shutting down
a lot of our power plants it's not that
we don't need the power it's that
they're going out of business because
the solar is this making it impossible
for them to stay in business so we'll be
bringing more coal power in from other
states at nighttime and so you have to
think this point may not be here in five
years and if you're gonna put something
in you need to be able to pick up and
move it
how is blue planet's carbon neutral or a
carbon negative concrete in terms of
strength durability is it similar to
standard concrete yeah we uh we have a
full concrete testing lab and we've
obviously passed all the ASTM standards
and we don't actually sell concrete you
know we've been using central concrete
which is the u.s. concrete affiliate
which built Levi's Stadium they do a lot
of work here on campus they did this PUC
building in San Francisco the Bay Bridge
deck other things in one of my classes
we talked about sequestering carbon and
serpentine rock is this the same
technology it's pressure buildup a
little concern when pumping the co2 into
the rocks below well that's not what
we're doing but the the geologic record
has most of the alkalinity we call it on
the earth
so if you remember your high school
chemistry alkalinity is the ability to
neutralize a proton so it's something
with extra electrons so Harold Urey who
was a famous chemist wrote a paper in
the 40s about what's called chemical
weathering it's where you know rivers
flow over rocks and interact with co2
and neutralize the co2 and he says the
co2 level of the earth is buffered by
the silhouette chemical weathering of
silicate rocks and all the alkalinity of
the earth is in the earth in the rocks
of the earth and that's absolutely truth
and I guess one thing blue planets
figured out how to do is to really
follow URIs guidance and you know take
the alkalinity of the earth just from
common rocks and neutralize all the co2
the BP technology seems Muraki
miraculous why isn't it more widespread
I think it will be actually you know
I've aim things at rapid scaling and as
Leslie mentioned this isn't the first
time I've sort of built a large carbon
sequestration plant I built the largest
one in the world down at Moss Landing
back in 2009 using a different
technology and you know you learn a lot
the first time around I think by
entering this agreement with this large
manufacturing company that can make all
the equipment and by having a basic
financing techni strategy where we're
not going to save the venture capital
community to raise money to build a
hundred million dollar plants I mean
that last command I raised that 182
million adventure money and had about I
don't know a couple hundred million
dollars in government grants and it just
was a drop in the bucket you know in
terms of what you really needed to make
something like this happen by instead
going on and accessing the project
equity markets which is how power plants
are normally financed by the way you
know excellent energy doesn't go out and
sell stock to build a power plant right
they go out and get equity investors and
that's how this should be done
it's sequestering carbon currently
profitable if not what are the largest
costs and under what circumstance will
it be profitable well that's sort of
what I've tried to answer is today it's
absolutely not profitable and the model
is that the Department of Energy is
going to pay for it and the Swedish
government and the Canadian government
and there's not even one percent of the
amount of money or technology they would
need to even begin to be successful but
they still keep spending the money we're
taking a different approach we're
looking at co2 as a raw material from
which we can make profitable products
that governments are already buying with
the money they're already spending state
of California spending you know over
four billion dollars a year on Rock
today well whoever wins this upcoming
election affects blue planet's mission
and goals we've already bailed on the
left and uh I'd say the lower 48 except
for California I'm spending 2/3 of my
time in Canada they've got a new prime
minister up there that's really
dedicated to what we're doing I'm
meeting with the first nations that have
a lot of the if you wonder who's looking
for those good IRS it's it's like the
first nations who are managing these
huge funds you know and are really
concerned about the melting of the
permafrost right now because they can't
even drive around in the summertime it's
all soot and what rate would co2
emissions need to be captured to have
any meaningful impact on climate change
we have already gone over 400 ppm
tipping point most developing countries
don't have the infrastructure to limit
co2 production so that's a great
question developing countries aren't
going to do anything to limit co2
production you know the poor people are
the higher the interest rate the first
thing that falls off is the environment
and then out a war to that and just
forget about the environment you know
people worry about starving
before they worry about the environment
so you know the grand illusion that
we're gonna have a global track
cap-and-trade system and Bangladesh
isn't gonna pay into it you know I don't
know what people are smoking that it's
not going to happen you know and you
really you have to provide a solution to
them it's like okay Bangladesh you're
pouring concrete you're spending all
this money that you could be spending on
this on paying people to barge in rock
you know from Vietnam you know what why
don't you use your dollars in a more
effective way but a meaningful change I
think is about 10 billion tons a year of
mitigation but when you look at the
increase co2 is increasing now it's not
decreased so you might be stabilizing in
North America and Europe but that's not
what's happening if you looked at the
science article around the world you
know it's probably got to start around
10 billion tons a year and grow to like
20 billion tons a year yeah yeah so for
rock you know we're currently money
about fifty four billion tons of rock a
year and paying for it transporting yeah
yeah so 10 million 10 billion tons of
co2 you produce about 18 billion tons of
rock yeah that includes adding the
oxygen and the calcium to it the
molecular weight of calcium carbonates
about 100 and molecular weight of co2 is
44 so 44 percent of each ton of
limestone is co2 direct air capture
strikes me as technology that is not
very useful now much cheaper options
currently available for decarbonization
yeah I guess I guess I don't know what
those are you know but but will be
extremely useful in 2040 2050 and 2060
once we have addressed the low-hanging
fruit
is this correct if so how can propose
technologies like co2 mineralization
Bridge that time gap commercially in
order to be ready 20 to 30 years out you
know I think everyone who wants to
decarbonize the atmosphere is a hero I
guess you know when you actually have to
implement stuff though one thing I know
designing these plants is the cost of
the plants is mostly determined by the
the cubic feet per minute of gas you're
bringing into them you know so if you're
bringing in gas from a coal plant which
is 15 percent co2 15 percent is 150
thousand parts per million the air is
400 parts per million right so it's like
1 430 you know it's so you'd have to
bring in 400 times more volume of gas to
process so it would cost 400 times more
to take it out of the atmosphere thing
to you and and you know if you look at
that 38 billion tons a year that humans
were putting out about 9.8 comes from
coal plants about 4 or 5 comes from
natural gas plants the rest come from
steel mills cement plants aluminum
refineries and then the other half of it
comes from transportation and if we
electrify transportation but we're still
importing coal electrons from Utah and
pretending you know driving up sand hill
road with our Tesla that says emission
free free power but we're charging it
with coal electrons every night you know
it's not going to get us anywhere
but what I have seen with direct capture
plants is they aim to capture about a
million tons a year and the cost of the
plant is a you know on the order of a
hundred million dollars so if you wanted
to do a 1 billion tons you need a
thousand of these plan
a thousand times 100 million dollars and
that's not even before you get to the
operation all parasitic load which is of
that million tonnes how many million
times did you generate just operating
the equipment and I guess with Sue gas
that diluted it's probably about half
you know so but you know there's no
doubt trees are one of the coolest ways
to sequester co2 you know it doesn't get
any better than photosynthesis right if
we could get the chemistry there that
would be awesome I have this one what do
you envision the best scale for your be
pre products to be if all building
materials in the US were made in this
way with the u.s. be carbon neutral and
do you see a limit to how much this
could be done the well the u.s. uses
about 2.5 billion tons of rockier so
just with the current rock that we're
making we could do well over a billion
tons just in the US you know I should
know this but of the 38 or so billion
tons the u.s. puts out it's a few
billion tons you know a lot of that's
transportation so you know we could cut
u.s. emissions pretty significantly you
know yeah the rocks that we bring in so
I right yeah no it's a great question I
skipped over that pretty fast most of
what we just bring in is just Rock and
it's it's a it's what we call
unclassified it's got all the fine
powders that they dispose of and fill up
the quarry in addition to the big rocks
that they cap grade to use in concrete
and a lot of that fine material is
actually processed in the calcium and
magnesium and iron and other things
dissolve out of it but we also
use waste materials like at the coal
plants were at they have decades of fly
ash piled up that the EPA wants them to
remediate and you know some of the
flashes are you know forty percent
calcium oxide fifteen percent calcium
oxide sodium oxide potassium oxide
magnesium oxide so we call it Geo mass
and it's meant to be they in the same
way when we talk about biomass you know
in a biomass reactor sometimes you might
have switchgrass sometimes you might
have woodchips you know and you're
adapting to a lot of different materials
I aspect ratio small percentage of very
high aspect ratio materials yes I would
imagine I don't know building them into
something else my food well every yard
of concrete in the US
well actually the world today has some
flash in it it's very rare like except
with the LA School District in a few
other places where they've outlawed fly
ash but you know there was a ten-year
controversy about putting fly ash in
concrete because it's a coal combustion
product and you know all these other
things but they decided it would be a
problem if you declared all concrete in
the u.s. a hazardous material and you
had to remove all of the concrete in the
u.s. start over again and you know the
reality is you know I used to make bun
cement for orthopedic surgery and helped
us standard establish the EPA specs for
bone cement and you know I can put bone
cement of your grandmother that's 50
parts per million lead but in that
operating room floor it has to be 50
parts per billion yeah so the FDA and
the EPA don't talk and then there are
concrete experts in the green building
industry who have no technical
experience whatsoever none who are
setting these standards so it's kind of
okay
discuss blue planets work on emitter
projects we uh we got a pretty great
grant up in Alberta a few years ago and
so we're working quite a bit up in
Alberta
both in cement and coal we're working in
Quebec Quebec carbon system is
synchronized with California's and
Ontario just joined it so you can earn
credits in Quebec and some in California
earn em in California and Salomon come
back
they have big alumina plants up there
because alumina uses a lot of
electricity and they have a lot of
hydropower they still have to burn
natural gas to generate steam and they
produce a lot of what's called red mud
which is probably the largest ugliest
waste in the world it's fouled out but
it's full of ions and alkalinity and
other stuff we're working at a like I
said in Wyoming and Utah coal plants
that import power to California so
they're paying whatever a $10 per
megawatt-hour
surcharge to ship it over the border
into California so they're incentivized
spent the whole company today with a
large natural gas produce power company
that has about 84 natural gas plants a
lot of them here in California you know
so for example that plant that I built a
with down at Moss Landing seven years
ago last year they paid thirty five
million dollars in carbon allowances and
I think they're gross it's a merchant
plant it's not a regulated utility
they're they're gross was like 700
million so 35 million off 700 million
starts to be a significant cost so
they're motivated to eliminate their co2
and what well a lot of them been
interesting in Mexico were working with
a big steel conglomerate and they teamed
up with a large cement company so the
cement company is gonna bring in the
rock they're gonna we're gonna take
they're right next to each other we take
the co2 from the cement plant and the
steel mill and then the cement company
is going to distribute the rock to so
the steel guy doesn't have to worry
about rock because a lot of them
complain they go look we've never worked
with rock
you know so if you bring someone in who
knows that the other thing we're finding
is we thought we were just gonna you
know go out and independently finance
these plants which is what I've talked
about a lot here and there's clearly a
lot of project equity financing whereas
it's just too big for venture capital
and what they're coming back and saying
it's no we want to own this you know and
you know if I'm a regular utility I'm
gonna put this through the rate base you
know take it to my PUC which is
unexpected I understood the cement
companies would want to own it because
it's already in that business because a
lot of them are vertically integrated
and they own not just a cement plant but
they own the quarry and the concrete
plant so they can distribute everything
themselves and that's really important
one of the concerns of emitters is well
what if you can't sell this stuff you
know I said of pileup that happened at a
plant in Florida where they were taking
sulfur dioxide converting it into gypsum
and they had to deal with us gypsum for
wallboard
and then the construction market tanked
and no one was buying wallboard and they
had 40 acres of gypsum and they were on
a manatee preserve and it was just total
nightmare have these efforts received
been received particularly by coal
plants if they're in Canada or
California you see big groups at
meetings you know shaking your hand like
this you know a smiley faces if if
they're in Ohio they may not return your
phone call yeah yeah I mean financially
the regulation doesn't really help the
economics but the reason you have to
have a carbon price is that that's the
only thing that's going to motivate
emitters you know and except creating a
financial incentive you know people are
you know this will be as particularly
true in China if you create
you know if government's say look
Caltrans you know Sacramento Jerry Brown
look Caltrans and Malcolm Dougherty
who's the head of Caltrans would
absolutely love to do this pathway you
know from now on all the concrete that
we specified for the high-speed rail
it's going to be carbon neutral concrete
you know we're not choosing a winner
doesn't matter how you do it but it has
to be carbon neutral you've just created
a huge market you know I was with the
folks at the high-speed rail and they
brought in the lady that's doing their
carbon you know life cycle carbon
analysis and I said well god that's
great how are you accounting for the the
concrete and she goes oh yeah we've
calculated all the truck routes you know
back and forth to lay the concrete said
yeah no I got that but what about the
concrete itself just oh we don't count
that you know if you look at the co2
footprint from the concrete in high
speed rail right that's all going to
happen when you build it right right up
front and then you say well if we if we
look at the transportation savings by
taking the train instead of driving a
Prius or something like that it's it's
not it's not a very clear picture that
you're gonna improve co2 emissions in
the state of California at least in the
first decade or two by pouring all that
concrete for the train to go over are
the costs and energy requirements of
carbon sequestration economically
feasible for a coal well with the
current approach not even remotely right
I mean so you know all the bankers are
always talking about you know what
effect is this going to have an 11 I've
cussed of electricity you know and you
know you look at utility scale solar
thermal and all these other you know
nuclear
natural gas you know other solar options
and they're all really expensive
but to actually sequester carbon dioxide
and then find these fields and build
pipelines and inject it underground and
monitor it and insure it you know makes
electricity extremely expensive so I
think right now if you take the policy
literally even under the president's
clean power plan where we would retrofit
coal plants to have the same emissions
as natural gas plants they really don't
have the technology to do it and in fact
we got started at a plant down in Tampa
Tampa Electric Company Big Bend Power
Station which is one of the biggest
plants in the southeast we had already
started our construction we cut a hole
in this hurt cig you know the flue stack
we built piping and they were acquired
by a company that's more into natural
gas and they decided just to repower the
whole station with natural gas even
though they don't have the natural gas
they're gonna have to build an LNG port
there just to bring natural gas you know
so coal is essentially going away right
now and and the thing is it's not going
away in most of the world it's only
going away in the United States it's not
going away in Europe you know Germany is
building new coal plants right because
they're out of nuclear now so so it's a
tough situation see I read up about blue
a plant and everything seems well and
good except for I've never heard of blue
planet before after creating a
technology how do you overcome the
challenges of mass implementation well
I'm a little bit you know that this
company I've built down at Moss Landing
I had a lot of venture capital investors
who were very helpful but I think they
were their descriptions of what we were
doing was sort of coming out too early
too much more you know over promising
and it was it was very difficult for to
be in that situation
and so we basically we haven't done
anything you know we've talked to the
press sometimes you know but it's very
limited
you know they quoted me in the Economist
a couple weeks ago about concrete we had
something in National Geographic over
the summer a couple page spread but we
really haven't we've tried to stay low
under the radar screen because there's
really no benefit to to have any
publicity for what we're trying to do
you know because it's not that those
aren't the people that are gonna make
the decisions you know and there's
there's there's just more negative see
you know you think everyone would be in
favor of if you're not a an actually
implementable way to actually address
climate change but it's not quite that
way
so we're just laying low but that was
the last question or were there any
other questions I see we're right on
time yeah they come the financials that
ninety nine percent IRR yeah why isn't
everybody beating adored it's up that's
in Hollywood ninety nine percent return
because it's a does he include all the
costs of marketing if you've got that if
you've got that model people should be
beating of the door down here funding
everything writing a check yeah well
that's that's that's what I'm saying is
that yes so the private equity investing
community has been uniformly ready to
finance these things but like I said a
lot of the emitters are saying you know
maybe we don't really want to be in the
rock business but you know we'd like to
own that and so all the sites I talked
about we have some kind of relationship
or you know they're owning it we're on
it
somebody's only there's a non-sequitur
but you're saying the problem is the
money but work on those numbers if
somebody should not be the problem right
I'm quite sure it's double-click yes I'm
differentiating between say I venture
capitalist who's managing someone else's
money and
getting paid to do that and they're
gonna cash out that money in three to
five years or seven years when their
funds done and project equity investors
who are looking for long-term returns a
decent raid with a lower level of risk
so they're not going to make a
thousand-to-one on this investment but
they may have a thirty-year consistent
investment it's more typical of the way
these things are financed and that would
be true when the owner of the the
emitter is providing you know putting on
their balance sheet to how many tons of
co2 have been taken out of the air today
well you know we're just building these
plants and you know I don't know there's
the San Francisco Airport that one tour
I showed you it was I don't know
probably 50 tons or something like that
but the the next step up is these two
and ten megawatt modular facilities
which each modules they're doing 25 tons
a day so you know if you have five them
that's 125 tons a day you know it's
really interesting we don't a lot of
people say well how much does this cost
per ton of co2 you know because that's
the metric if you're thinking of it as a
waste and you're just gonna inject it in
the ground you just want to know what
your cost to remove the waste is right
and we don't even think about it that
way you know we say how many tons of
product can we get into the green
building world to sequester co2 because
if any of the agencies that actually you
know they're these protocols that have
to be validated by third parties you
know if we're gonna say we sequestered a
thousand tons of co2 in this concrete
pourer we have to be able to prove that
you know if we're ever gonna you know
get any kind of credit for it so we're
in both financially and
from Carbon County point of view we're
focused on how much God sequester into
the into the built environment it's the
way we think about it and what is the
cost per you know ton of rock would be
the way we make our decisions yeah
brooch clients to get the modules
installed and also this loose planet
also we're calling on the part we were
like getting legislators to implement
this renewable more creative San
Francisco Airport was blue plan directly
involved wasn't just indirect oh right
yeah so if you mean clients by people
that are buying carbon negative concrete
like with the San Francisco Airport they
hired a consulting firm to tell them how
to make the greenest Airport and as you
could see that sort of the Alita the
Green Building world are also part of
Blue Planet so I mean even if we were to
produce ten million tons tomorrow it
would all be gone and we'd be out you
know because the you know everyone wants
to specify carbon negative concrete
right so from from the the product side
you know I don't know if we could ever
satisfy the demand because from the
built environment point of view a
concrete is the 900-pound gorilla and if
you can eliminate that and have carbon
neutral buildings you could
revolutionize the whole built
environment from the emitter side like I
was saying you know Southern Company has
no reason Duke power they have no reason
to even be interested in any of this you
know but a company in Canada or
California would on the legislative side
federally you know main thing is the
federal highway bill there's a lot of
other avenues but you know surprisingly
who's really good as a Department of
Defense and what's different about them
is when they want to do something they
just do it
you know it's different and so the Navy
said we're gonna have all our airports
carbon-neutral by 2017 it they're doing
it I mean they're actually you know it's
not like maybe kind of you know they're
gonna make it happen you know so so
that's that's kind of been interesting
but I mean the main lever it like I've
been saying all along the government has
is is not funding things it's it's by
just using their purchasing power you
know and using it responsibly yeah just
wondering is there like a policy drive
to get governments to codify any of this
into need alleged legislation and I'm
just wondering it do you have a strategy
on that and what are you gonna do future
yeah we we have about six people yeah
one of the my vice presidents is in
Washington he's a enviromental law
professor at George Mason and he also
used to work for the Portland Cement
Association and the National ready-mix
concrete association and you know we've
gotten do he grants together in previous
companies so we are working on that that
whole process it's it seems to be a
nonpartisan bill that usually gets
passed so but you know there's a lot of
concern about not choosing winners you
know there's really no one else making
carbon- concrete so even if you didn't
say Blue Planet you know they you know
but yeah we are did that cover the first
part of your question yeah I'm just
wondering if there's any like specific
laws that you're looking at and there's
a long-term strategy to integrate more
of this yeah it's a federal highway bill
which gets renewed every few years and
there's other versions of it and then
here in California we you know the
legislature specifies like this crumb
rubber material and all that but we are
suspect in we pass all the tests you
know there's no you're not compromising
safety or quality or durable
or even price yeah yeah
what's the efficiency of the process
yeah
add the sequestration on to an existing
right power plant
how much extra power power input does a
plant require in order to produce it
yeah that's a good question it I skipped
over the slide sort of quickly but so we
call that a parasitic load you know
that's one of the big things about what
we're doing is we have a less than a 10
percent parasitic load which sounds like
a lot you know it can be a hundred
megawatts on a gigawatt but anyone else
even coming close to this is got a 40
percent parasitic load just to separate
the co2 you know so yeah it's not it's
nothing's free that's for sure I mean
and that's true you know solar at
building solar panels huge carbon
footprint you know windmills big carbon
footprint Tesla's gigantic footprint you
know you know it's just getting into
that full carbon life cycle thinking you
know yeah I wasn't sure your timeline or
in your mouth if you currently have
customers that own this industrial
dependent that's currently turning out
or if that's still agent
yeah so you know like with this past
company unless they was discussing I
hired 85 engineers and we would build
everything and we still had contracts
with everyone but I've done with blue
planet is stay kind of lean and mean
we've got a bunch of scientists and then
we have an owner's engineer which is a
large engineering firm it's engineering
everything but then we have a contract
with this one hundred ninety thousand
person manufacturing company it's all
over the world you know so they do all
the procurement and assembly of all the
equipment and so yeah we have the sign
signed agreements with our partners who
are commercializing with us
you